BOB ANDERSON: Thank you
all for coming tonight.
I'm Bob Anderson.
And on behalf of the MIT
Enterprise Forum of Cambridge,
I want to welcome you all to
this evening's presentation
of the 50K Competition
final event.
The MIT Enterprise
Forum of Cambridge
has been hosting the 50K final
event since it started in 1990.
We are thrilled to highlight
the extraordinary talent, ideas,
and enthusiasm for
entrepreneurship that exist
within the MIT student body.
The Forum's mission-- to help
entrepreneurs build successful
companies--
fits well with the
student run activity.
And the forum will be a
resource for these teams
once they've graduated and
begun the serious business
of building a company.
Our jumpstart clinics,
startup clinics,
[? 10250s, ?] spring
and fall workshops,
and technology briefing
series all help entrepreneurs.
The MIT Enterprise
Forum of Cambridge
is celebrating its 20th
anniversary this year.
Begun as an educational
service to MIT alumni,
the forum has
broadened its reach
to include not only
the MIT community,
but the entire entrepreneurial
community of New England.
There are also 18 enterprise
forum chapters worldwide,
all dedicated to promoting the
growth of technology oriented
companies.
And in fact, they're
often linked.
On May 21, Professor
Bob Langer will
be giving a satellite
broadcast out
of [? Crusky. ?] More
information on that
is in the brochures
at the entrance.
Here in the Boston
area, these teams
also find a great
infrastructure of resources
to help them build
their companies.
One example are the
volunteers and the sponsors
of the MIT Enterprise Forum.
I want to thank
tonight's sponsor,
Goodwin, Procter, and Hoar,
for their long-term support,
both of the forum and
entrepreneurs in general.
You should all have
a fun time tonight
I extend my congratulations
to all the 50K entrepreneurs,
especially tonight's finalists.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome everybody to the ninth
annual MIT 50K Entrepreneurship
Competition.
So what's on tap for tonight?
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER: What is
on tap for tonight?
First we want to talk
for a moment about what
is the MIT 50K for some
of you who haven't run
into the competition before.
Then we're really excited
to have Bill Porter,
founder and chairman of E*Trade
[? Group ?] [? Inc. ?] coming
to share some words of advice
with these teams who are
launching their ventures.
Next we'd like to
introduce the organizing
team that will be running
the competition next year.
And finally, the part that
we're all here for tonight,
each of the finalists teams will
be presenting their business
ideas for you, and
you can be the judge.
And at the end of
the evening, we'll
find out who are judging
panel chose this year's 50K
grand prize and
runner up winners.
First, before we continue, we'd
like to thank our sponsors.
Our sponsors give
us the money that it
takes to run the
competition every year
in addition to the
$50,000 worth of money
we give out as prizes each year.
We also take about 50 to $60,000
to put on each of the programs.
We have several events sponsors.
Motorola New Ventures sponsors
our team building dinners
each month.
Testa, Hurwitz, and Thibeault
sponsors the Intellectual
Property Seminar.
Polaroid sponsors our Ideas
and Innovation Seminar.
And McKinsey and Company
sponsored our first
ever Global Startup
Workshop for organizers
of business plan competitions.
We also have many
other sponsors who
provide the services,
the money that it
takes to keep our lights
running and our office going
and our faxes going
out every year.
And we have
sponsorship from alumni
who have given back
to the competition
Silicon Space, our inclined
sponsors who provide services
to the teams coming
out of the competition,
and very importantly,
our sponsors within MIT,
including all the groups here
and MIT Resource Development.
So what are the steps of the
50K we start in the fall.
We had 1K warm-up round.
We had 120 entries in that.
The judges selected 10
teams to identify and honor
as teams showing great promise.
We came back in the
spring with our kickoff,
the executive summaries
and semifinalist plans due.
And tonight, we're here
at the 50K final awards.
So we've seen the process.
But what are the results
of this network, process,
and resources?
In the past nine years,
over 30 companies
have come out of
the competition.
They've created over 500 jobs
and have an aggregate market
value of over $180 million.
And it's not just these
large aggregate numbers.
It's stories like Virtual Ink,
a 1997 winner of the competition
just received $1 million
worth of seed investment.
[APPLAUSE]
They've recently moved
into office space
with one of our
sponsors, Polaroid,
and will be launching
their product in Q4 in '98.
Right?
Stylus Innovations
sold their company
that won the competition in
1991 for $12.8 million in 1995.
Web Line, a 1996 winner,
received $7 million
worth of venture
capital last year.
And most interestingly,
two of our alumni, Flash
Communications and Firefly, were
both purchased by Microsoft.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
You be the judge.
The finalists that you see
here tonight are tremendous.
But they are not the
only ones going forward
to launch their ventures.
And tonight's is a
celebration, a commencement
of the ventures for
all the teams that
have participated in the 50K.
I'd like to take a moment
and have each of these teams
stand up so that you
can identify them,
seek them out afterwards,
and say hello.
Beacon Software.
Can you turn on the lights?
Beacon Software, Exotech,
Biomedical Modeling,
Frictionless Commerce,
Catalyst Software,
[? Net ?] [? Pecker, ?]
Connected Care,
[? Netican, ?]
Cortical Technologies,
Past Technologies,
Ethos Technologies,
and [? Vert ?] [? Med. ?]
[APPLAUSE]
Just have to get my
notes so I don't forget
anything really important here.
Now I'm very pleased to
introduce to you Bill Porter.
He's the founder and chairman
of E*Trade Group as we mentioned
earlier and near and dear to the
heart of MIT since he's class
of '67.
He founded the E*Trade company,
formerly known as E*Trade Plus
in 1982.
Prior to founding E*Trade, Mr.
Porter held research management
positions at General
Electric and Textron.
He received a BA in mathematics
from Adams State College,
an MA in physics from
Kansas State College,
and an MBA in management
from the MIT Sloan School.
Mr. Porter retired as
chief executive officer
in April 1996.
In May 1996, Mr. Porter was
named Silicon Valley's emerging
company entrepreneur of the year
by San Jose Business Journal.
And most excitingly,
Mr. Porter has just
founded a company,
which is operating
in stealth mode, that promises
to be very, very exciting.
Bill Porter.
[APPLAUSE]
BILL PORTER: Thank you.
Well, I feel pretty
humbled to be here at MIT.
You know, the intellectual
stimulation at MIT
is not surpassed any
place that I know.
There are so many bright people
on the staff or on the faculty.
And the students here are
just absolutely outstanding.
And so all I can do is
tell it like I see it,
and I will do just that.
What I'm going to do is
talk just a little bit about
E*Trade.
And then I have
some other things
that I would just like
to pass on as ideas
about entrepreneurship.
We originated online
brokerage in 1982.
We were the very
first ones to do that.
And I started with
another fellow.
And we spent 10 years
getting it going.
And so it takes a
lot of perseverance
to make things happen.
And finally, we founded E*Trade
the beginning of this decade.
And during the '80s, we actually
serviced Schwab, Fidelity,
Quick & Reilly, and a number
of other broker dealers
where we were basically
a service bureau.
And we formed E*Trade as such
in 1992, which was only-- what--
five years ago or six
years ago, I guess it was.
And we basically
have led the market
in terms of price decrease.
I established the
strategy early on
to decrease the price as
a function of our volumes
to maintain profitability
and with a total objective
of obtaining essentially
market recognition
and be the brand leader,
which we have achieved.
And there's our
six years growth.
The overall growth-- I forget
in the first couple of months,
which was infinite, of course--
the overall growth
month to month averages
today for the whole
six years 8% a month.
And you'll see a
little dip there
at the tail end of last year
and the beginning of this year.
As you may remember toward
the end of last year,
there was a dump in the market.
And sure enough, our market
decreased accordingly.
But people come
right back after--
they forget those things
very quickly, thank goodness.
And of course, we're in a
very hot market as well.
Well, we have arrived
at a point where we
have very competitive prices.
There are some people that
are lower than we are.
But we're satisfied with
where we're at for right now.
And it's a very
competitive situation.
And people do a
lot of trading when
it's this inexpensive to trade.
Now, as an aside, just one of
those little gems of knowledge
if you ever want to pass
it on, one of the things,
you'll notice that
the prices that you
see for online brokerage is all
like, you know, 14.95 or 19.95,
or 7.95, et cetera, et cetera.
Where the $0.05 come from?
Well, as I mentioned,
you know, I
price decreased over the years.
In fact, I cut
prices seven times
since, I think it
was about four years.
And in doing that, we
were let's say $30 or $35.
And so then I'd bounce
it down to 30 from 35.
And so at one
transition of that type,
one of my stockholders
of the company
said let's have
our annual meeting.
Let's just get
together for lunch.
So OK fine, so Steve came
over, and we went out to lunch.
And I said, Steve,
guess what, on Monday,
I'm announcing the
fact that we're
going to go from $35 to $30.
He said, no, no Bill.
He says go to 29.95.
So I said, OK,
that's a good idea.
Mind you this guy
was from car parts
business, very successful.
He knew how to do
the merchandising.
So I adopted the 29.95.
And the whole
industry has followed.
Now, you might be interested
to know that I have calculated
that that $0.05 per trade
amounts to about $400,000
a year to the industry.
That's a lot of nickels.
Anyway, the customer
acceptance, we
have about 450,000 accounts,
$10 billion in customers.
But do we do about 45,000
trades a day currently.
We have cracked
the $50,000 mark.
I'm sorry, 50,000 trademark,
which is a lot of trading.
And we've done over
10 million trades
to date without any
real serious problems.
We have 9% to 10% or pardon
me 8% to 9% per month growth.
And we were ranked as the
fastest growing company
in Silicon Valley.
And on top of that,
we have about 200--
this is from the last
quarter, so we're
a little higher than this now.
Shouldn't say that, but I will.
204 million annualized revenues
and 20% pre-tax 200 million
in cash.
And we're saving that
cash, because there's
a lot of new entrants.
They're not all
going to make it.
And come a drop in the
market, they'll be hurting.
And our plan is acquisition.
And that's the reason we
built this work chest of cash.
And we have over
a billion dollars
in assets, no debt whatsoever,
about 750 employees.
But again, we're
growing at 8% a month.
So that number is very dynamic.
And we had an IPO a year
and a half ago at about $10,
and our stock price
today is about $25
with a P/E of about 60.
Now I want to turn to a totally
different story, because I
want to make a point with it for
the entrepreneurs in the room.
I had an idea.
And while I was in college,
I didn't have any money,
so I had to work on
the railroad at night
on the D&RG out in Colorado.
And I noticed that the
roundhouse workers, the fellows
that worked in the roundhouse,
they understood steam engines,
but they didn't know what a
diesel electric locomotive was.
And on top of that, they
were very highly unionized.
They had an attitude of,
well, very highly unionized.
I'll leave it at that.
OK.
Then in about 1965 when I
was working as an R&D manager
at Textron, I found
that as a company,
we were producing automotive--
or pardon me, checkout
equipment for aircraft.
And it struck me, why
not see if maybe there's
some application here on
diesel electric locomotives?
And so I took that idea.
And I took it to the
Southern Pacific Railroad.
And there was a fellow there
who was actually the finance VP.
And he and I got together at MIT
and proceeded with the concept.
And so we started a
development program
to produce some automatic
checkout equipment
for diesel electric locomotives.
And GM did not like the idea.
You can't touch my diesel
engine, et cetera, et cetera.
So we had a few battles
to fight, which we won.
And the program was
highly successful.
And the Southern Pacific's
data at that time
showed that about 20% of
their locomotives, including
locomotives on the
road were not working.
In other words, they were
not pulling as they should.
And they estimated,
also, that the Textron--
that's where I was
working at the time--
automatic checkout system
would cut the losses in half.
And of course, we were
looking for shorts, opens,
and so forth.
We put a harness
into the locomotive,
the electric locker,
and had a plug-in piece
of equipment sitting beside
the track and so forth.
And so we sold the system.
I sold the system to a number
of different railroads,
about a half a
dozen major roads.
And at the time, there
were 33,000 locomotives
in operation in the US.
And therefore, I really feel
that I was instrumental.
And somebody else would have
done it if I hadn't, but I
did it.
And I put 3,000
locomotives on the road.
And that's a-- you know,
I'm kind of proud of this.
And really, I was making,
I think, about $25,000
a year at that
point in time, which
was more money than is today,
it seems like, but not a lot.
And really, why did I
tell you this story?
Well, really for two reasons.
And I'm really directing
this to the folks that
are entrepreneurially inclined
and leaving here and so forth.
And you know, it's
the achievement.
To me, it's the achievement.
It's the accomplishment of
doing it that really counts.
And--
[APPLAUSE]
I mean, don't get me wrong.
The money is nice, but it
isn't where it's at, you know.
Don't pay attention how
much money you're making.
Get the job done.
That's what really counts.
And the other thing
is that there's
all kinds of opportunities
for entrepreneurially
inclined individuals,
who can just
look at things in everyday
life and see things
to be done and go do them.
So there's just no
shortage of things
to be done in our society
for the benefit of society.
Well, speaking of
opportunities just a little
bit, as I see it in the
coming century and borrowing
on the idea of plate tectonics
and so forth, sources
of energy.
I mean, you know, we're going
to run out of coal and oil
and so forth.
And what are we going
to do to replace it?
And that is a real problem
I see coming in the future.
I remember when I first
left, got my masters
and went to work for the Bureau
of Standards in Washington.
I met a fellow who was working
in the Interior Department,
and he said, we're going
to be out of oil in 1975,
I think it's what he said.
And I don't know
what the estimate
is today is probably the
year 2030, and by 2030 maybe.
But someday, we'll run out.
And it's really
important to pursue that.
And unfortunately, I
don't think our government
does enough in that dimension.
But I think there's some
real opportunities there.
And worldwide commerce,
there's no question about it.
We are expanding E*Trade, for
example, on a worldwide basis.
And there's all kinds
of opportunities
all over the world, particularly
in the underdeveloped countries
to help them kick start.
And you don't necessarily
make money there.
But I think there's
a lot to be said
for the achievement of making
mankind's position better.
Environmental protection,
no question about it.
I think this past century
has really been one of wars.
And I don't think we're going to
have any more significant wars.
I hope to heck and I'm
sure everybody else does,
that that is true.
But the coming
century has just got
to bear down on the whole
subject of the environment,
no question about it.
I was in Manila recently.
And it's just almost
deplorable the situation there
from an environmental
point of view.
And something has to be done.
A lot of things have to be done.
And there's opportunity there.
The information
age, I hardly have
to say anything about that.
What I see the other day that
the amount of content online
is doubling every 100 days.
And of course, that
makes it doubly difficult
for some of the internet starts
that you hear about and so
forth.
But the sorting of that and
the use of that and so forth
provides all kinds
of opportunities.
And actually, you've
heard of disintermediation
and all of the
things that brings
about in terms of opportunity.
But also there's a whole
subject of partnership
and joint venturing between
various organizations
on the internet.
So it just creates all
kinds of opportunity.
But you know, if I could ask the
good Lord to give me 100 years
to watch one science evolve,
it would be this one, the life
science, engineering,
because I really
think that what will happen
in terms of our ability
to change life as
we know it today,
both people and their plants
and foods and everything else,
is just absolutely going to
explode over the lives of you
young folks that are
graduating today.
And I just think
it's a terrific area
to pursue, particularly when you
couple it with the information
age.
I really think it's going
to change the whole fabric
of our society.
And so just the
combination of those two,
I think is one of the most
exciting areas to pursue.
Well, just as one
of those areas,
and I'll just flip through
this quickly, is excess trash.
You know, my wife and I, our
kids are all grown and gone.
We fill one to two
trash cans a week.
It's absolutely ridiculous.
And most of it comes
from packaging.
And there's all
kinds of things that
could be done in the packaging
domain that are not being done,
I believe, and still
maintain good marketability
of the product.
And catalogs, we
probably get two
or three catalogs every day.
It's absolutely ridiculous.
And what can be done?
There's opportunities
in recycling,
produce electricity or
fertilizer with them,
combine with the internet to
reduce the number of pages
or whatever, thinner
paper, paper substitute,
pass new laws.
There's opportunities actually
in Congress and so forth
to do things of an
entrepreneurial nature that
need to be done.
There really just are a
multitude of opportunities.
I just illustrate this
with just one dimension.
Well, the essential
characteristics,
as I see it of an entrepreneur,
are the key ingredients.
I don't know what you
want to call it exactly is
first of all basic integrity.
And there are so
many people who seem
to lose that in the
business environment
once they get into it.
And they kind of
manipulate things
a little bit and so forth.
And I just don't think
that's the way to believe.
You know, in the long
haul, the only person
you have to report
to is yourself.
And when you do that, you want
to be able to stand up and say,
I did it right.
And too many people just
go litigious and crazy.
And just don't ever do that.
That would be rule
number one in my book.
And look for the opportunities.
You know, they're
all over the place
of things to change and
new markets, new products,
and services.
And they're very
good for society.
And you know, most of them are
pretty obvious things to do.
And do your homework.
When you have an idea,
really dig into it,
see what the competition
is, what the market is,
what your product is, what it's
going to cost, et cetera, et
cetera.
You really got to
do your homework
to be absolutely convinced
you're right, even though you
may be partially wrong.
And when you are certain, there
is no question, go for it.
Don't stand back
and say, well, geez,
you know, somebody
could do to thus and so.
Go do it.
This is America.
It's OK to go belly
up and start again.
You know, you can't do that
every place in the world.
But here, you can.
And all it really
costs you is maybe
you have to go out and
get a job for someplace
else for a little while.
And it's OK to do that.
And stick to your
guns, because there's
going to be many people
that tell you, you're crazy,
you can't do this, et cetera.
If you've done your homework
and are convinced of it,
just stick to it.
However, you got to be ready to
make changes when you find out
that, hey, it wasn't
really quite that way,
and I have to go a
little bit to the left
to get around this corner.
So you do have to make changes.
But basically, you gotta
plow ahead and stick to it .
And I don't know if they ever
teach you this in your finance
class, but cash is king.
You've got to have the
money to get there.
You've got to protect it.
You've got to take
good care of it.
Fancy offices don't
mean an awful lot.
What counts is being able to
meet the payroll, et cetera.
And along with cash
is king, there's
another area that I think
is equally important.
And that is marketing is queen.
And without a king and queen,
you won't get there from here.
You know, particularly
for technologists,
they think that they
have this hot idea,
and it probably is real
hot, and they maybe
have done their homework, et
cetera, in terms of technology.
But I got to tell you,
these two elements
are absolutely necessary to get
there from here, particularly
the marketing.
And of course, you've got to
have the cash for the payroll
and so forth.
And finally, as I said earlier,
work for the achievement.
Don't worry about the money.
If you do a good job,
the money will come.
And you can quote me.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: That was so cool.
Before we continue, we
need everybody to stand up.
Up.
And look into the center
and see if there's
an empty seat next to you.
And if there is,
move to the center,
because we have people
standing in the back,
and we'd like them to be able
to sit during the presentation.
Here we go.
Squish.
All right, everybody in?
You can sit down.
That was our intermission.
We're up to the
part in your program
that says Organizing
Team Transition.
The competition is organized
by students for students
here at MIT, and we've
had a great team leading
the competition this year.
It's been wonderful
to work with them.
And I would just like to
recognize them and have them
stand up so you can meet them.
We have Maya [? Hansen, ?]
who graduated early,
leading events, Scott
Blanksteen, who took her place,
communications who's
leading the evangelism part,
Pat [? McCormick, ?] operations
of communications is Dave Chan,
sponsor relations Andy
[? Sweaky, ?] and Margo
[? Gore ?] [? Stockman, ?]
who is graduating this,
year but has made a major
contribution to the core team
as well as [? Lona ?]
[? Plantier. ?] Can you please
stand?
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
Let me tell you a little
bit about what the team has
put together this past year.
Our goals were to
really maintain
the quantity of
entries that we had
while increasing the quality and
building infrastructure to grow
the competition in the future.
And we met those goals.
This fall, we had
120 1K entries.
Our team size match
last year with 3.9
in the spring competition.
We're up to 5.6 in
our finalist teams.
We had 30 full business
plan submitted.
We wiped out our debt.
Go, Andy.
And we increased our
sponsorship dollars.
We've had some
tremendous additions
to the judging panel from the
West Coast venture capital firm
from successful entrepreneurs
and some great professional
services.
We sponsored the first ever
Global Startup Workshop,
which is like a lot of words.
But those words really
mean it's the first venue
for all organizers
of business plan
competitions around the world
to get together and share
best practices.
We sponsored the first
alumni reunion in preparation
for our 10th year next year.
We've received international
media attention
from CNN and from Japan
Public Television, who
are here tonight.
And best of all, we have a
great team for next year.
Before we go on and
introduce that team,
I want to say thank you
to all our sponsors.
And I would read their names.
But this competition is
really a tremendous network.
And if you turn
to page nine, you
can see all the people it takes
to put together a competition
like this during the year.
It's just a tremendous
contribution
from each person
that is listed here,
and we want to thank them.
[APPLAUSE]
And now, the part I personally
have been waiting for
is to introduce the
organizing team for next year.
They're wonderful people.
Gert-Hartwig Lescow
is leading events.
Our communications person,
we're still recruiting.
Sponsor relations, definitely
in control with Dave Magnoni.
You guys can please stand
so they can find you later.
Eve Phillips is leading
the alumni mentor program.
And before we introduce
Scott and get him up here,
we want to introduce the
rest of the core team,
and I have to get my list,
because it's pretty large.
Please stand, [? Sachen ?]
[? Devecha, ?] [? Moder ?]
[? Fu, ?] [? Chef ?] [? Hong ?]
[? Kwong, ?] Richard [? Li, ?]
Pat [? McCormick, ?] [? Xtian ?]
[? Mersa, ?] [? Monus ?]
[? Rafa, ?] Paul Rosenstein,
Joel [? Surface, ?] [? Chuck ?]
[? Sestak, ?] and Dave Yang.
Thanks so much, you guys.
[APPLAUSE]
And now I'd like to
introduce Scott Blanksteen,
lead organizer for next
year, first year Sloan
MBA, and a good friend.
Thanks, Scott.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN: Thank you.
Good evening.
I'd like to thank Sally first
of all for the great job.
She's done this year
coordinating all of this
and helping us all learn
the process a little better.
[APPLAUSE]
The other important
members of the team
that haven't been mentioned
yet are the judges
who help us choose the finalists
from these great set of plans
we get.
And I'd like to read
each of their names
individually, because
I think they spend
a lot of time, a lot of
effort writing feedback
to each of the teams, providing
advice, and just helping out
with our own process of
running this competition.
So we have Mark [? Gorenberg ?]
from Hummer [? Winblad ?]
Venture Partners.
And if you'd like to stand,
that would also be great.
Dan [? Hart, ?]
Fundamental Capital.
Adam [? Hoenig ?] from Sea
Bridge Internet Solutions.
Mitch [? Kapor, ?] founder
of Lotus Development.
[APPLAUSE]
[? Omar ?] [? Cadari ?]
of [? Via ?] Web.
Duncan [? McCallum ?]
of One Liberty Ventures.
[APPLAUSE]
Ed Miller of Testa,
Hurwitz, & Thibeault.
[APPLAUSE]
David Morgan [? Thaler ?] of
Morgan [? Thaler ?] Ventures.
[APPLAUSE]
John [? Pitchioni, ?]
Sullivan & [? Werster. ?]
[APPLAUSE]
Edmund [? Pitcher, ?] also of
Testa, Hurwitz, & Thibeault.
[APPLAUSE]
Robin Plummer of Wolf,
Greenfield, & Sacks.
[APPLAUSE]
Bill [? Podeska ?] of Advanced
Visual Systems, and also
the founder of Prime
and Apollo Computers.
[APPLAUSE]
Dan Roach of Coopers
& [? Librand. ?]
[APPLAUSE]
Dan Schwinn of
[? Avadine ?] & [? Sheva. ?]
[APPLAUSE]
Blair Whitaker of
Norwest Ventures.
[APPLAUSE]
And George [? Zachary, ?]
who made the trip out
from California to be with us.
[APPLAUSE]
We really appreciate the
work this fine team has done.
And yesterday, we
had them locked up
in the room for seven
hours because we
had such a great set
of finalists this year
to choose from.
And I think that's
really reflected
in some of the comments that
came out of that session.
We were told that, in fact,
the plans that came in here
are better quality than
the plans they receive
for funding consideration.
And I think that's
an amazing testament
to the effort people put in
to entering this competition.
And the judges also
were very happy to see
how the teams and the
plans improved over
the course of the
competition from the status
of an idea in the fall
to an executive summary
to a full business plan.
And we hope we can
take some of the credit
with some of the educational
events and programs we provided
during the year.
And finally, of
course, the disclaimer.
You may not agree with the
choices the judges have made,
and that's great, because as
we saw before, at least a dozen
teams are planning
on going forward,
notwithstanding the
results of tonight.
And I think that's great, too.
So the best part
of the evening, we
get to introduce and
hear from the finalists.
As we see, there's no
particular order to this.
There's no ranking.
It's simply the order in which
they presented to the judges
yesterday.
I'll read the names,
and then we'll
have them each come
up here in this order
and give a short
10-minute presentation
as they made yesterday.
First team is SiliconTest.
[APPLAUSE]
The second team is CarSoft.
WeddingBell.com
[APPLAUSE]
Volunteer Community Connection.
Akamai Technologies.
[APPLAUSE]
And finally, Direct
Hit Technologies.
[APPLAUSE]
And to start us off, we'll
have the team from SiliconTest
up here.
ROHINI CHAKRAVARTHY: Hi, my
name is Rohini Chakravarthy
I'm a first year Sloan student.
And I will go with a brief
overview of the business
plan for SiliconTest.
It will be briefer than
the 10 minutes allotted,
so we can get to
the winners quicker.
Let's start with a
challenge statement.
SEMATECH, which is a
semiconductor industry
consortium, has articulated
in its National Semiconductor
technology roadmap that
over the next eight years,
high frequency
[INAUDIBLE] probes
will be a major roadblock.
SiliconTest plans to address
this challenge squarely.
The company was founded
in February 1998
and has its roots in
our CEO's graduate work.
We plan to provide probe
cards for chip testing
based on new technology
that's more scalable and more
cost effective than
those currently used.
To give you a brief
idea, basically chips
are made on silicon wafers.
And while they're
still on a wafer,
a probe card sits on
them, and you test
each chip for functionality.
So we plan to make new
kinds of probe cards.
The company, Arvind Purushotham
is the President and CEO.
He is currently working
for a large semiconductor
manufacturer.
I will be the VP of Marketing
and Sales, and as I said,
I'm a first year Sloan
student right now.
We also have William Huffman
who is not here today,
but he will be the
VP of Engineering.
And he is an expert in
testing and packaging
and has worked in the
area for 14 years now.
We also have two future
recruits who have committed
to join us pending funding.
The market opportunity
itself is--
it's a large market,
450 million as assessed
by [INAUDIBLE]
research for 1997.
And it's set to grow
at 25% following
the growth of the
[? IC ?] market
at least over the
next few years.
The industry is characterized
by tight customer and supplier
relationships.
Basically, what happens is every
time a new chip is designed,
a probe card has to be custom
designed to go with it.
And so the semiconductor
manufacturer and the probe card
manufacturer act as partners
in developing this probe card.
So the relationships
have to be really tight
as you work with the customer.
It's a fragmented market.
There are many
important players,
but no one player holds the
majority of the market share.
And all of them seem to use
precision machining based
technology.
So the underlying technology
is fairly homogeneous.
The major customers are
semiconductor manufacturers
here in the US, in Japan,
and in Southeast Asia.
So examples would be Intel, AMD,
Motorola, Lucent, and so on.
So to start off
with this venture,
we plan to request
funding in stages.
The first milestone will
be a prototype development
milestone.
And optimistically speaking,
we will need about 1.3 million
to achieve this milestone.
We also believe we will need
an additional 1.5 million
at least to reach the first
customer acquisition milestone.
So who are the logical
investors for such a venture?
It's not uncommon in this
industry for semiconductor
manufacturers to take equity
positions in key suppliers
since they invest so
much time in developing
these relationships.
So we will look
at those customers
as possible investors.
Also, industry associations
that are a possibility.
SEMATECH, for
example, although they
don't take equity
positions, do offer
technical and
financial assistance
to startups that show
industry changing potential.
And finally, angel investors
and seed venture capitalists
will be valuable
sources of funding.
They will bring in financial
assistance, as well
as their networks
within the industry,
and we look at them as very
positive sources of funding.
So why do I believe SiliconTest
is a great investment?
We have a very clearly
identified market need.
We believe we have
the right technology
and that this is the
right time to deploy it.
We have assembled a
uniquely qualified set
of people, people who
understand both the technology
and the customer environment.
And through our contacts,
we have unusual access
to the customer, to
the first customer.
Finally, we believe we have
a huge upside potential.
It's a great market.
It's waiting to change.
And we believe we can change it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN: OK, the
next team up is CarSoft.
CHUCK MYERS: Hello.
We'd like to thank everybody
right off, especially Sally
and the organizing committee.
This has been a stellar event.
They have done a fantastic job
putting this thing together.
And we sincerely
offer our thanks
for all the hard work and
the late nights they put in.
Next, we'd like to thank
the judges for selecting
us to get this far.
We were fairly honored
to be here tonight.
And next, I think you'll
find through the CarSoft
presentation that maybe
we and Bill Porter
have a little bit in common.
CarSoft is know what
your car is thinking.
See if we can find the
page down button on this.
There we go.
First of all, I'm Chuck Myers.
I'm on board to offer the
strategic and marketing
initiatives to the company.
I'd like to introduce
Diego Borrego.
Diego is the father
of this brain child.
And we classify him somewhat
as a little eccentric
and our technical leader.
And Morten Gunnarshaug
is our operations guy.
And he's here to make
sure that Diego and myself
don't kill each other.
What is CarSoft?
What we've done is to create
a hardware and software
product that links
the car's computer
with an outside
processing source,
like your home PC or
any other database.
And with that, I'd like to turn
it over to Morten Gunnarshaug.
MORTEN GUNNARSHAUG:
Thank you, Chuck.
Thanks to all of you.
I'll say something
about the market.
The market we will
target basically
consist of two segments.
The first segments as GearHeads.
That is people who
work on their cars
and also know about
computer and look like this.
They are quite easy to target.
They are online.
And we think that'll be
a low cost to find them.
The second market, it's
consumers, like you and me.
And there are about 39
million diagnostic checks
performed each year in
the US markets of cars.
And AAA price for this is about
$50, which would in this market
would be about 2 billion.
The opportunity
for this market--
or the market's pain is that
car owners and general fear
mechanics and
dealers and depending
on where you live in
the United States,
you have to bring your car to a
smog test or annual inspections
once or twice a year.
And the solution
for a problem I'll
hand over to Diego to
tell some more about.
DIEGO BORREGO:
Thank you, Morten.
CarSoft solution,
our painkiller.
CarSoft intends to
provide consumers
with an easy to
understand version
of the same kind
of information that
is used by only highly
trained automotive technicians
and mechanics today.
And we plan to do
it at a low price.
Why now?
Why can we do this now?
Why is this the right
time for CarSoft?
More and more, there
are computers in cars.
There are more higher
power computers in cars.
There's more
processing in your car.
There's more electronic
sensors in your car.
Wireless technology
is coming of age.
It's more ubiquitous.
It's available at a lower price.
There's a proliferation,
of course, of the internet
and of PCs.
We all know that.
Perhaps the strongest
reason why now is the time
is because of EPA
mandated regulations now
that stipulate that
these cars have
to be able to
diagnose themselves
and have greater and
greater capabilities.
So the information is there.
It's in your car.
We plan to give it
to the consumers.
Why CarSoft?
We have an inexpensive design.
We believe it's a unique design.
It leverages the processing
power in your home PCs
or any other type of computer.
And also, CarSoft is
positioned to provide
unbiased information.
We don't make money
from selling parts.
from selling repairs.
We can tell you the
truth about what's
going on inside your car.
And with that, I'll let Chuck
finalize our presentation.
CHUCK MYERS: What CarSoft
has, we have people,
we have founders that are
committed to this project.
We have founders that are
committed to moving forward
with this business.
We think it's a good business.
We think it's a strong business.
And we think that there's
a strong underlying
fundamental soundness to it.
We have maybe, again, a
little bit like Bill Porter,
we have some developers already
working on some prototypes.
And we'll say that they're
in stealth mode as well.
And our technology
is readily available.
And what's our future?
We see this as being a service
and an information business
as we go along.
We don't just see it as
one device or one product
in the beginning.
We see it from the
continuous monitoring
of the vehicle performance.
We see us as being
that content that a lot
of these web-based
sites are looking
for that we can actually
maintain owner profiles,
and we can maintain all of
the history of the vehicle
as the vehicle
goes on in its life
and as the owner
changes vehicles,
and they want to know
when to service their car.
So again, we think
we're a content
provider for those sites.
And we think around
our business,
we can build and create
these internet communities.
As we were saying
before, Diego's
a member of the fine
gearhead community.
And these guys are on
the web day and night
talking to each other.
We think this is our business.
And we think that we can
move forward and really
turn this into something.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN:
Well, thanks, guys.
That was really great.
As soon as I finish paying off
my MIT loans and buy a car,
I'm right there.
Next up is something a little
different, WeddingBell.com.
STEVEN ROSENBLATT: Good evening.
Actually, I don't think
I was this nervous
before my own wedding.
So you know, just bear with me.
My name is Steven
Rosenblatt, and this
is my colleague, Peter Stein.
And we'd like to welcome
you to our WeddingBell.com
presentation.
You know, most people
are under the impression
that the most difficult question
asked with regard to a wedding
is, will you marry me?
In fact, this is
not true at all.
We found some more
difficult questions
that are being asked through
the course of the proceedings.
Well, maybe not.
For instance, the
engaged couple might
ask, how can we let everybody
know where we're registered for
all our wedding guests?
The wedding guests may
ask, how could we find out
where the engaged
couple is registered
for without having to ask them?
Or they may ask, how
could I get to a store
and purchase one
of these gifts when
I'm real busy working all
day and don't have time
to get to one?
Finally, the retail
stores may ask,
you know, this wedding
registry business is growing.
How can we expand our customer
base and become part of it?
Well, WeddingBell.com is
aware of these concerns
and has found a solution.
WeddingBell.com will provide
any retail establishment,
regardless of its
size or location,
an internet-based, full-service
gift registry system, which
will allow end users,
being the wedding guests,
to purchase gifts from
an engaged couple's
registry from the convenience
of their own home or office
24 hours a day,
seven days a week.
Today, we're going to talk
about the WeddingBell.com
team, the potential market in
the online wedding registry
business, our value proposition.
We're going to present
our business model,
talk about the risk of an
internet wedding registry
business, and then we'll have
some concluding comments.
Obviously the key to success of
any organization is its team.
WeddingBell.com currently
consists of six members who
have diverse professional--
I didn't even get
to the joke yet.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
You all have to laugh when
I get to that part again.
We have diverse relevant
professional experiences
and skills.
Tonight, I'd just like to
highlight for the members.
Peter Stein is our
President and CEO.
Peter will be
responsible for the day
to day operations
of the organization.
He has experience in
IT project management.
And he'll be graduating
from Sloan this June.
He also has very relevant
wedding registry experience
in that he's currently going
to be married this November.
I am the Vice President
of Sales and Marketing.
I'll be responsible
for selling the systems
into the retail stores
as well as handling
the day to day finances.
I, too, will be graduating
from Sloan this June,
and I still am familiar
with the registry process,
as I was just married
this past June.
Next we have Josh Tolman, who's
our Vice President of Product
Development.
Josh will be responsible
for system implementation
and internet programming.
Josh has four years
experience as an IT systems
consultant, an
internet programmer,
and fortunately, he will become
very familiar with the process
as he's currently
contemplating engagement.
Last but not least,
we have Luke Tuttle.
Luke is our Vice
President of Technology,
who will be responsible
for network implementation.
Luke has a BS and a master's
degree in computer science
and programming.
And unfortunately, he has no
idea what the wedding registry
process is all about as
he's still currently looking
for a date.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
That's good.
Thank you.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
Before we talk about
the potential market,
I think it's important to
examine some of the trends that
currently exist.
First, more people are
registering for wedding gifts
than ever before.
Brides Magazine-- yes, I do read
Brides Magazine-- is currently
completing a survey,
and they found
that 90% of the engaged
couples register
for wedding gifts in 1996 as
opposed to only 60% in 1993.
Trend number two.
This is probably pretty
shocking to everybody.
More people are using the
internet than ever before.
Internet Data Corporation
estimated in 1997
that there were 50 million
users on the internet,
and they estimate this number
will reach 175 million in 2001.
Trend number three.
Not only are more people
using the internet,
but more people are making
purchases on the internet
than ever before.
American Express estimated
that there were $5 billion
in purchases on the
internet in 1997,
and they estimate this
number to reach $80 billion
in the year 2010.
These trends, based
on our projection
of a 10% penetration into
the wedding gift market,
we foresee the total potential
online wedding registry gift
market to reach $250 million
in 1998 and $544 million
in the year 2002.
Now Peter will talk about
the WeddingBell.com value
proposition.
PETER STEIN: Thanks, Steve.
Steve just hopefully
demonstrated to everyone
that there is a market for an
online wedding registry system.
Now I want to show people
how it'll help the customers.
We have three types
of customers--
engaged couples, the wedding
guests, and the retail stores.
The engaged couples,
with our system,
will be able to register in any
type of store, large department
stores or small boutiques
that you would find perhaps
on Newbury Street.
These little stores,
all they need
is a computer and an
internet connection,
and they're all set up
with a wedding registry.
There's no need for
the engaged couple
to worry about registering
for one gift in a small store.
They don't have to alert their
wedding guests which stores
are registered in, because
the wedding guests can
go to the internet and purchase
the gifts whenever they
want right over the internet.
They can also purchase the gifts
from the store if they want.
While on the internet, they
can search by gift type
if they want to
just get something
in the linens category,
or they can also
search by costs, if they're
only willing to spend
a certain amount per gift.
Lastly, the retail stores.
The retail stores,
especially the smaller ones
and the ones that currently
don't have registry systems
will have an enormously
expanded customer base.
Obviously, with the
internet, people
who aren't located
near the retail stores
will be able to just,
again, go on the internet
and purchase gifts from there.
Therefore, WeddingBell.com is
the entire registry solution,
the online solution and
the in-store solution.
Our business model, this is the
way we're going to make money.
We've done some surveying, and
we've talked to some industry
experts.
And we've found that
the retail stores
are willing to pay a setup
fee and a maintenance fee.
They're also willing to
pay a percentage of sales.
This helps us a lot.
We get fees from them
in two different ways.
The wedding guests-- that's the
little yellow people there--
we're going to charge them a
surcharge, only about $2.95.
You might find
yourself saying, well,
would I be willing to pay that?
But if you think about when
you buy a wedding gift,
you really have a
gift giving threshold
that you don't want
to spend more than.
And as long as the gift you
buy falls within that range,
we found that the wedding
guests we surveyed
would be willing to pay.
Also note that we're not
charging the engaged couple.
If anyone out there is
getting married, don't worry,
you won't have to pay
a cent for our service.
A lot of our competitors
charge you, however.
We also found that the
engaged couples just
don't think it's fair.
It's their day.
They don't want to be charged
to put gifts on their registry.
With any startup,
there are risks.
So WeddingBell.com
has its risks as well.
Our first risk is having
reliable system operation.
A lot of people have
tried to buy gifts
from certain department
stores in the area,
and they find that their wedding
registry systems are down,
or they can't get the printouts,
or they can't buy the gifts.
Well, we're going to defend
that with redundant connectivity
to the internet.
We're also going to
have local front end
software that the retailers
will have in their store,
so that even if the internet
connection goes down,
they'll still be able to enter
all of their registry orders.
We realize also that
obtaining customer commitment
is vital to the success of
WeddingBell.com as a business.
But we've developed
a marketing plan
and through our
promotions and our PR,
we plan to get the wedding
guests, the engaged couple,
and the retail stores to buy
into this network all at once
and have it grow
extremely rapidly.
Finally, we know
that this business
has some low barriers to entry.
It's not that difficult
for people to get into it,
but we plan to combat this by
having a first mover advantage.
We want to quickly
establish our network,
and we plan to do that
through our business model
and getting the engaged
couples and the retail stores
as well as wedding guests all
into this at the same time
and through a very
specific entry strategy.
We hope to raise
that entry barrier.
Finally, Steve is going
to come back and give you
some concluding remarks.
STEVEN ROSENBLATT:
Thanks, Peter.
So why is WeddingBell.com
ready to go?
First off www.WeddingBell.com
is registered with InterNIC.
We could already
establish a brand identity
through this URL.
Second, we already
have five retail stores
have given preliminary
commitments
to have the system
installed into their stores.
Third, as I mentioned,
the timing's
right with the internet
and e-commerce boom.
And finally, we just
have a dedicated team
of really good people
that are really committed
to this project.
WeddingBell.com, we're ready
to revolutionize the wedding
industry today.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN: Thank
you very much, guys.
OK, the next team is
something very special.
It's a Volunteer
Community Connection.
And here they are now.
JOHN: Hi, I'm John,
and this is Mike.
And we're here to talk to
you about revolutionizing
volunteerism.
MIKE: Non-profit
agencies and volunteers
have thus far failed to
converge on the internet.
We offer an online
solution to bridge
the gap between these volunteers
and nonprofit agencies.
Volunteers will now
be able to easily find
the opportunities for
which they are looking,
and nonprofit agencies
will be able to efficiently
recruit and manage the
volunteers that they need.
This potential market
is, simply put, huge.
There are 50 million Americans
who volunteered last year.
25% of these Americans
are already online.
And as you've heard many
times today, this number
is doubling in the
next two years.
There are over 10,000
large corporations
who are just now beginning
to develop company
wide volunteering efforts.
At $450 per month, this
represents a total market
of over $50 million.
And there over
550,000 nonprofits
looking to recruit
and manage volunteers.
At $25 per month,
this represents
a market of over $160 million.
This market has been
unaddressed today.
The internet offers only
static and passive access
to volunteers.
Nonprofit agencies can only
list things on the internet.
There is no active
recruitment of volunteers,
and there is no management.
As a result, volunteers of
today are alone and confused.
We offer the solution.
The VCC solves the
problems of volunteerism
for volunteers, nonprofit
agencies, and corporations.
Volunteers will be able to
find the right opportunities
for them, simply
by saying things
like, I want to
volunteer with education,
with kids, clicking
Search, and it's done.
Nonprofit agencies will be
able to recruit volunteers
on the internet, offline,
online, together,
and effectively manage them.
And corporations
will all of a sudden
have an easy way to begin
company wide volunteering
efforts.
How does this work for you
and me, the volunteers?
We log into the VCC website.
And so we select
what we want to do.
What could be easier?
We hit Search.
And right away, we
see the agencies
that offer the opportunities.
We are a nonprofit organization.
And as a nonprofit,
our primary goal
is to serve the agencies and
volunteers in our communities.
For the agencies
in our communities,
we recruit groups of volunteers,
whom we call the web tutors.
Web tutors work at
nonprofit agencies,
teaching them about
technology, about the internet,
and about email.
These are things that some
of us may think are normal,
but nonprofit
agencies have thus far
failed to achieve the resources
to learn these technologies.
We recruit volunteers to
show them why it is useful
and how to use it.
We also run volunteer fairs,
conferences, seminars,
online forums,
activities to link
nonprofit agencies and us, the
volunteers, together in person.
JOHN: But the reason
we're here tonight
is because of the services
we're now planning
on offering to our agencies.
An example of our
value proposition.
We look at Boston
Cares, a medium
sized nonprofit in
the Boston area.
They send out monthly mailings
to about 2,000 volunteers,
spending overall $7,000 a year.
It's really just a
shock and approach
to their 2,000 volunteers.
And it's only once
a month a mailing
of about 50 opportunities,
not targeted at all.
We offer something
completely different.
For only $25 a month, we
offer targeted e-mailings.
We offer unlimited, basically,
access to our volunteer base.
So if we have
100,000 volunteers,
they really only target 10%.
But those 10% are committed
volunteers to their cause.
And we do this constantly
as they add new projects,
saving them $6,700
or 95% of which I
guess you could call their
volunteer acquisition cost.
We're planning on taking this
value proposition nationally.
Starting out slowly this year,
recruiting 1,000 agencies
and about 39
corporations, moving
to 37,000 agencies and 1,000
corporations in our fifth year.
And that's only
4% of the market,
because this market is huge.
In order to expand
to these numbers,
we need to concentrate
on two things--
our sales and marketing efforts.
In order to do this,
we're going to target
three specific markets--
volunteers, agencies,
and corporations.
We're going to target
these through three
very different ways.
For volunteers,
we're going to use
online ads, banner ads on Yahoo,
Excite, and other portals.
For agencies, we're going
to use direct mail and phone
contact, utilizing the IRS
database of over 700,000
nonprofits in the United States.
And lastly, corporations.
We're going to dispatch
people from the VCC
to contact the CEOs
and HR people directly
to get involved in their
corporate volunteer Programs
As we add more agencies
and more volunteers,
we need to have a management
staff in place that's going
to be able to handle this.
And currently, we have a
dedicated management team.
We have Emily Sandberg
on our board helping
to drive and direct the VCC.
We have Rich [? Sanford, ?]
one of the founders of the VCC,
who's in direct contact with
the agencies on a daily basis,
identifying their needs.
Mike [? Bryzyk ?] and [? Umi ?]
[? Mehrotra ?] developed
our software and have now split
up with Mike working on sales
and marketing and [? Umi ?]
developing the final release
of the software.
And I'm John, and I'm
responsible for the business
plan and focusing on
sustainability for the VCC.
And the VCC has been running
for about a year now.
And in order to reach a
level of sustainability,
we think we need to focus on
the following three steps--
funding, management,
and partnerships.
Let's start with funding.
The 50K is really just a
stepping stone for the VCC.
After the 50K, we're
go and approach
larger foundations
such as the Boston
Foundation for larger grants.
At the same time, we're going
to be working on our management
team, recruiting a CEO,
someone with national volunteer
or nonprofit experience
or maybe someone
from the corporate world to
help us take this nationally.
We're going to work on our
sales and marketing materials
and work on the final
release of the VCS software
for release in September.
And lastly, while
we're doing all this
we're constantly
working on partnerships,
online partnerships
such as boston.com,
university partnerships, such
as Boston College, Boston
University, and
community partnerships,
like Boston Cares.
Achieving these three
steps will allow
us to reach our goal of
revolutionizing volunteerism.
The VCC services have
never been offered before.
We increase the ease
of volunteering,
and we increase the
satisfaction of volunteering
because we offer volunteers
targeted positions
at these agencies.
And we've been growing
steadily since last year.
And additional funding at
this key moment for the VCC
will allow us to launch in
September and reach our goal.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN: Great.
And let's see.
We're two thirds of
the way there now.
We've got two more teams to go.
Next team, Akamai Technologies.
JONATHAN SEELIG:
Hi, good evening.
I'm very honored to be
here representing Akamai
technologies [INAUDIBLE].
Perfect.
Look good?
I'm very honored to be
here representing Akamai
Technologies this evening.
Couple of
technological glitches.
My name is Jonathan Seelig
I'm a first year MBA student
at the Sloan School at MIT.
And I wish to present to
you global hosting servers.
Akamai Technology
intend to change the way
that content is distributed
throughout the internet.
I have three things that I'd
like to present to you tonight.
One is the team that we have
assembled for this venture.
We're very proud
of it, and I'd like
to show you the people
who we have involved
in Akamai Technologies.
I'd like to introduce
you to the technology
that we have in place
and the technologies
that we are developing to
push this venture forward.
And then I will pass off to my
colleague, Preetish Nijhawan,
who is a second year
student at the Sloan School.
And Preetish will give you some
information about our market
opportunity and how we plan
to expand into that market
opportunity.
The Akamai team.
I can't walk around
without the cordless.
The Akamai team.
The Akamai team has a very
strong marriage of technology
and business acumen.
On our technology side, the
leader of our technology effort
is Professor Tom Leighton.
Professor Tom
Leighton is the head
of the algorithms
group at the Laboratory
for Computer Science at MIT.
He is joined by Professor
David Karger, who
is also of the algorithms
group and a doctoral student
in that same algorithms group,
Danny Lewin, who was formerly
an IBM Research fellow.
On the implementation
side, we have Bill Bogstad,
who has over a dozen years of
Unix development experience,
Robert Thau, who was the
primary developer of the Apache
server, which is the dominant
web server that is used today,
so has greater market
share than Microsoft
or the Netscape, very,
very successful product.
And added to them, we have
Alex Sherman, Yoav Yerushalmi,
and we have a group of
10 students on board
to bring this product to market.
On the business side,
we have the good fortune
of having been joined recently
by David Crosby, who was
formerly of Sitara Networks.
David has extensive telecom
experience as well as
experience in the
internet space.
Steve Papa, who we
are fortunate to have,
was formerly with Inktomi, is
currently a student at HBS.
Preetish Nijhawan, formerly
with Intel and Marco Greenberg,
who is a public relations
expert out of New York City.
Our team of advisors has
been phenomenal to us.
They've done a great
job of keeping us
on track, a lot of
prominent people up there,
a lot of prominent names.
And we are very lucky to
have them in helping us
with this venture.
Let me tell you what the
mission of content providers
is on the internet.
Content providers have a
very, very simple mission.
They want to attract
people to their sites,
and they want to
keep them there.
In order to do this, there
are some very simple things
that they need.
They need fast, easy,
and reliable access
to their sites for the clients.
They also need
personalized content.
Personalized content allows
these content providers
to make the user experience
unique for every single person
who makes it to the site.
In order to do that, they use
fancy graphics, multimedia,
and a variety of other
bells and whistles.
But there is a problem today.
The problem is that
the ISPs is who
hosts this content
can't give the content
providers the quality of service
that they are looking for.
This results in a
phenomenon known widely
as the worldwide weight.
There are a couple of sources
of the worldwide weight.
One is flash crowds.
People get to a
site on the internet
because there's something
exciting going on there.
The Monica Lewinsky
story breaks.
Everybody floods cnn.com.
When this happens,
the content becomes
phenomenally popular,
the servers are swamped,
as is the network.
This can cause such
significant loading
that the network will
actually go down,
and nobody gets access
to this content.
A second problem that
we have is that there
is tremendous distance between
the end user and the server.
This costs money,
and it takes time
to get content to the end user.
Akamai Technologies-- Preetish--
Akamai Technologies has a
breakthrough in this space.
We have breakthrough
technologies
that will allow ISPs to
host content at literally
thousands, even hundreds
of thousands of locations
worldwide with the
flip of a switch.
In doing this, we will have
content that will always
be close to the user.
Intelligent replication
of the content
will handle flash crowds.
Content that the user
receives will always be fresh,
and we've implemented these
technologies in such a way
that they are transparent
to both the end
user and the content
provider and that they
will run on standard
inexpensive hardware.
One of the things that
we've done in this
is that we've introduced some
revolutionary technology that
is the first step
in truly building
an intelligent internet.
Let's show you just a
couple of little examples
of how we are going to make
this world of the internet
a better world using
our technologies.
The way the world looks
today as a user at CNN--
a user somewhere over in
Europe anywhere in the world
wants content from, for
example, cnn.com out of Atlanta.
In order to get there, there is
a long and winding and terribly
complex path that
they need to go by
to get to the cnn.com site.
The content needs to
travel a long distance
through a complex network.
What we propose through
the Akamai network
is a distributed
series of servers
that we have called global
hosting servers or ghosts.
The name ghost is used
because these servers are
invisible to the users, they
are invisible to the content
providers, and they basically
perform this service
of speeding up access
on the internet
while being completely
invisible to all users.
How does the network look
with these ghosts in place?
A big mesh that gets built out
and looks terribly complex,
but is easily understood
by these ghost servers.
They have dynamic ways
of finding each other
on the internet.
They're completely fault
resistant, because it doesn't
matter if one of them goes
down, the rest of them
know how to find other
elements in this network.
And what's going to happen
to the content from cnn.com
is it will arrive
to the user from one
of these closed
servers, not necessarily
the closest, but certainly one
of the ones that's very, very
close geographically.
We do this in such
a way that we still
allow the content provider that
is cnn.com to personalize pages
and to know exactly who
arrived at their page.
And this is something that
is unique to our solution,
and it is something that content
providers have specifically
asked us for in our
dialogues with them.
That's a brief overview
of the technology,
and I will hand off to Preetish.
He will give you
some introduction
to the market opportunity.
PREETISH NIJHAWAN: Hi.
My name is Preetish
Nijhawan, and I'm
a second year student at Sloan,
all set to graduate, I think.
The market potential for
this technology is huge.
There are various
internet projections
out there, most of
which are wrong.
We know that.
But we have to
take what we have.
They range from $12
billion to $16 billion
in 2002, currently
less than a million.
According to the
Wall Street Journal,
the hosting market is expected
to grow at about 250% per year.
And we intend to ride that wave.
This does not include the
potential applications
for the enterprise market
or the internet market.
We intend that to be a follow
on market that we will consider.
John.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
So how are we going to do this
from a marketing standpoint?
We intend to build partnerships
with the hosting services,
which are the ISPs, or the
internet service providers.
And very importantly, we
want to build partnerships
with the content providers.
We're the only
solution out there
that looks out for
the content providers.
As Bill Porter just said today,
the content on the internet
doubles every 100 days.
We love that.
That's very good for us.
We want to inform the content
providers that there is really
a solution out there that's
going to get their data closer
to the users, make it
faster, keep the users there,
and nobody else does that.
We intend to go on
identifying market demand
for our technology
and also carve
out an exclusive market niche
for our Akamai to dominate.
I'd like to conclude
by saying four things.
One is that we have a unique
technology that really
is poised to change the way
the content is disseminated
over the internet.
We have a capable
and committed team.
You saw the whole list.
It's a large and rapidly
expanding market share.
One thing we learned
in business school
is always be part of an
upward exponential curve.
We intend to do that.
And finally, we
intend to continue
to build partnerships
and a customer base
to really revolutionize
the internet.
Thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN: Excellent.
We've now come to our last
presenters, Direct Hit.
GARY CULLISS: We are
Direct Hit Technologies,
and we are a company that
takes existing search engines
that you use on the internet.
We make them a lot
better, so that you
can stop looking for information
and start finding it.
The problem is that
with the internet being
such a huge mass of data,
it's tough to locate
relevant information.
As you all know,
search engines often
return a lot of
irrelevant results.
And in fact, 90% of all
users in a recent survey
have said that they want
more targeted search results.
So this problem is
only to get worse
as the internet
continues to grow.
It's currently estimated to be
about 300 million documents.
And that number is expected
to exceed 1 billion
by the year 2002.
The way current
search engines work,
take Infoseek, Alta Vista,
Excite, the other search
engines, they look
to the keywords
that authors put in the
document in the meta tags
to provide the
relevancy rankings.
This is the position of the
search result in the list
that you get back.
The problem with
this is that you
can get a lot of
irrelevant documents,
and quite frankly, you
get too many results.
So the editors at Yahoo
have a different approach.
They actually have a staff of
people surfing the internet
and looking for websites.
They classify them according
to categories and keywords.
Problem with this is that it can
be labor intensive, expensive,
and quite frankly, they're
struggling to keep up
with the growth in the web.
Right now, they have
approximately 1%
of the internet indexed.
Direct Hit is going to take
a totally different approach
to this problem.
We're going to actually
empower the users to organize
the search results.
Our rankings are based
on what people actually
select from the hit list.
So what you get is a
market for information,
where the sites that people
select move up in the rankings.
The ones that they ignore
move down in the rankings.
So our premise is that with
each search engine being visited
by approximately 20
million people a day,
there's a high likelihood
that somebody else has already
found what you're looking for.
Direct Hit allows you the 20
million searchers out there
to automatically rank
those documents for us.
You don't have to do anything
that you're not already doing.
Now, how does all this work?
The searches are re-ranked
by what searchers like.
We have proprietary
software algorithms
that know exactly what sites
previous searchers liked
and did not like.
And it's totally automatic.
The searchers don't
have to do anything
that they're not already doing.
The result, as I
mentioned before,
is a market for
information where
the good stuff rises to
the top, the bad stuff
sinks to the bottom.
Let's take a look at a
current search engine.
This is a search query
for Boston MBTA, which
is a local transit authority.
People go to the site to
look for subway schedules
and commuter rail schedules.
And you can see that
this is actual results
from a current search
engine on the internet,
and it's giving pretty
irrelevant results.
You've got Boston apartments,
internet search tools,
the Hong Kong students
will know about and Boston
links for information.
With the Direct Hit
technology, by monitoring
what people actually
pick from the list,
we can provide much
better relevancy ranking.
You can see here that
the official website
of the MBTA, which
is the best hit
is actually listed number one,
along with a few other highly
relevant documents.
These are actual results
that are generated
with our current prototype.
So how do we make
money from all this?
Well, our business
model is not to compete
with the search engines, but in
fact, to partner up with them.
We've already got two
of the four major search
engines who have agreed
to add a link to our site.
And what's going to happen is
if a user types in a search
query and gets results
that they're unhappy with,
they can click on our
button, a direct hit
will deliver a page
that's re-ranked by what
other people have actually
selected for a similar search
query.
We're going to be co-branded
with the existing search
portal.
And the way we
actually make money
is we present a new ad banner.
We've created some
additional real estate
that we can sell ad
banners on, and that we
have an ad revenue
sharing agreement
with our search partners.
Additional markets
for the technology
include search driven
commerce sites,
like netmarket.com and Chemdex
which sell specialty chemicals.
Corporate internet document
servers can also benefit,
and smaller website owners who
we can sell separate software
for their search driven sites.
Our competitive
advantages include
our current strategic
alliances with two engines.
We are complementary,
our technology.
It's not competitive
with search engines,
because users can choose
between the pure search
results and the results that
other people have found.
We're going to be the first to
the market with the technology.
Our business model
is technically
and financially risk free
to the search engines,
doesn't interfere with their
existing legacy systems.
We have a competitive pricing
because all of our deals
are non-exclusive.
And if none of that
works, we still
have four patents pending.
And with that, I'm going to
turn it over to Mike Cassidy
to explain the numbers
bind the business.
MIKE CASSIDY: Thanks, Gary.
The important thing to
notice from this chart
is actually the number of daily
page views being generated,
including Alta Vista,
which is not shown,
today there being
120 million page
views a day, 120 million times
people are searching and seeing
result. And the growth
rate is incredible,
between 100 and 200% per year.
The key for our
revenue generation
is what fraction of those
pages we can capture.
This model shows that
by the end of the year,
there'll be 200 million pages.
If we can capture 30 million
of those with our partner,
and if we can get a 25%
ad share revenue, which
is quite typical
in the industry,
typically we partner up
with Alta Vista or someone
like that, they will take 20%
off the top from the ad revenue
and then split the
remainder half and half
between us and them.
So if we can do
even less than that
and assuming a much lower
ad revenue also, typically
in the industry today, you'll
be able to charge $50 to $60
per 1,000 for keyword search.
We're only assuming
$20 per 1,000.
We can quickly generate, as
you can see, $30 to $40 million
worth of revenue.
I just want to talk
briefly in a conclusion
about the team we have.
Gary, who you've already met is
the inventor of the technology.
Despite the fact that he's
from Harvard Law School,
he's got an
entrepreneurial mind.
He was a patent
agent for four years.
He's giving up his law career.
And as a patent
agent for four years,
he did a lot of searching.
So it's one of the nice
stories where he saw firsthand
every day the weaknesses
of the existing technology.
Steven Yang, a key member
of our team, an MIT senior,
created the prototype that
we showed to these two search
engines, who were so
impressed by the prototype
that they agreed
to work with us.
A little bit about me.
This is a sort of a
second time around for me.
It's a lot different
than in 1991.
In 1991, [? Christina ?]
[? Holly ?] and I were part
of Stylus Innovation,
which won the contest.
We sold the company
in '96 for 13 million.
I went to Berkeley School
of Music last year,
was minding my own business,
but sort of got the bug again
and saw what Gary was doing.
And they had the
whatever you want
to call it, enough
guts to say, let's
bring on a CEO who's
done this before.
We also have some
expert developers
on the team, some people
from Fidelity who've
done a lot of their hot online
transaction processing stuff,
people who've previously
worked for Yahoo
and other companies like that
who have a lot of expertise.
Also, we have [? Eileen ?]
[? Lang, ?] the former CEO
of Alta Vista, who is equity
owning member of our board
of directors.
So in conclusion,
I'd like to say,
I guess since we're the last
team, I get the last word,
I certainly hope we win.
But I hope I speak
for everyone here
that the quality
of our competitors
and the presentations, which is
the first time I've seen them,
is phenomenal.
And I certainly
will have no regrets
if we lose to one of them.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN:
I'd like to echo Mike
in saying that I thought
these were really
great teams, great ideas.
And I wish them all
the best of luck,
and I'd like to
applaud them myself.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: About
eight years ago,
something very important
to me happened.
I met John [? Barris ?]
and Mike Cassidy.
And why is that important?
They're incredible teammates
that pretty much would
be the people I'd work with for
the next six years of my life,
probably the most exciting
six years of my life.
We started Stylus Innovation.
And as people have already
mentioned, we won the 10K.
It was a 10K back then.
And it pretty much kicked
off very exciting times.
We grew incredibly fast.
We invented Visual Voice,
which was a computer telephony
development tool for Windows.
We became very successful.
We hired 20 people by the time
we sold it for $13 million.
And I have to also
say, enough about me.
I have to say that this
competition has also
grown incredibly fast and
furiously since we won in 1991.
And I'm so impressed with
the work that they've done.
I think that if the
organizers were putting
their efforts and their
talents into actually starting
companies right now,
I think there'd be
more millionaires amongst us.
And I'm sure that they will
be doing that in the future.
So the reason why I'm here
is because we thought Stylus,
it would be very nice
for us to finally
be able to give back to the
competition that really gave us
a lot, wonderful networking
opportunities, I can say,
you know, just great push to
actually put a business plan
together and great advice
and, of course, $10,000
isn't bad either.
So we would like to
give back $10,000
to one of the two runners ups
of this competition this year.
So going to open up the
envelope here to find out.
It is CarSoft.
[APPLAUSE]
DIEGO BORREGO: Well, of
course, this is a surprise.
But just once again,
I'd like to thank
the organizers, the judges,
everybody who's helped us out.
We had a lot of different inputs
from a lot different advisors.
They've all been of great help.
And hopefully, you'll be able
to buy our product pretty soon.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN: Our second
presenter tonight is Mr.
David [? Morgan ?]
[? Thaler, ?] longtime friend
of the competition, provided
us with our bridge round
of financing when we were
on the rocks a few years ago
and ensure the continued
functioning of this
organization.
And we'd like to have him
come up here and introduce
the next team and present his
own surprise announcement.
Additionally Mr. [? Morgan ?]
[? Thaler ?] was the recipient
just recently of the 1998
National Venture Capital
Association Lifetime
Achievement Award and Mr.
[? Morgan Thaler. ?]
[APPLAUSE]
[? DAVID MORGAN THALER: ?]
Thank you very much, Steven.
It's a great pleasure to be
with this group again tonight.
About five years ago,
Lester Thoreau and I
were talking about
what should be
done with Sloan
School for a gift
that my wife and I
were going to make
and wanted to
dedicate it to Sloan.
And Lester deserves
credit for saying
that the enterprise, the 10K
program deserved support,
and it needed some
continuing financial support.
So we made a two-year commitment
and joined in the program
in that those years.
We were so happy with the work
that the students were doing
and the quality of the contest,
the quality of the business
plans, that we have
continued to support.
We renewed and we
have continued now.
And I think we're
into about five years.
And I must say that I
remain extremely impressed
with the teams, with the work
that the students have done,
with the work and
dedication of the judges,
with the extremely fine business
plans that result out of this.
And so I'm very happy to
be with you again tonight.
And Sally and Steve deserve--
Sally and Scott deserve
tremendous credit
for what they've done with
their teams working on this.
I'm not deliberately
stalling about giving you
an answer as to the
grand prize winner.
I simply want to tell you we
had a very unusual and very,
very pleasant occurrence
in the judging this year.
The quality of the
plans were so good,
and there was so much
discussion among the judges,
a tie vote at the end among it.
And so it was decided that
there would be two first prize
winners.
Now, customarily, in the Nobel
prizes and things of that kind,
when that sort of
thing happens, it's
customary to split the prize.
But no, that will
never do for MIT.
[AUDIENCE LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
And so for the first time in
the history of the contest,
with the help of an extremely
generous donor, who absolutely
insisted that he or she
must remain anonymous,
there is a full first
prize available for each
of two contestants.
[APPLAUSE]
And I have the honor to announce
the first of the co grand prize
winners.
And this winner is--
the co grand prize winner,
Volunteer Community Connection.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE: Thank you very much.
We are just
completely shocked we
are a nonprofit organization.
[APPLAUSE]
As all the teams competing
know, it's about silent heroes.
And we have had the
fortune of having
one of the greatest teams.
And a lot of these
team members are
people you have yet to meet.
And so I'd like to
introduce them now.
You already know myself Mike and
John [? Allen. ?] Next to John
this is [? Umi ?]
[? Mehrotra. ?] He's been one
of the key software developers.
And next to [? Umi, ?]
Emily Sandberg, Director
of the Public Service Center.
And on my right here, this is
Rich Stanford, who is just--
this team has just
really come together.
In addition, we'd like to
finally think the 50K staff.
You guys have been wonderful.
And the entire staff of
the MIT Public Service
Center and the judges.
And there's one other silent
hero in the audience tonight
who has just been a
complete resource in terms
of the business
plan and support.
And my father, [INAUDIBLE]
flew out from California
this afternoon to
be here with us,
and he has just been a
support all the way through.
So thank you to everybody.
And we hope you volunteer.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN: Well,
that was exciting.
And finally, for our
last grand prize winner--
four to choose from.
We have Mr. Ronjon Nag,
currently the general manager
of Motorola Lexicus division,
which may remind you
of the team that was also
in the competition in 1991,
Lexicus Longhand was
his team, was recently
bought by Motorola.
And he is currently
working there.
And he will--
well, of course, we
must mention that he was
the fastest MIT alumni
ever to make it to the
cover of Fortune Magazine
after graduation.
[APPLAUSE]
Mr. Ronjon Nag.
RONJON NAG: Thank you.
This is a very exciting event.
I'd just like to say a few
words for the people who
haven't won today.
I was one of probably
the equivalent
of the 84 teams
in the first round
who didn't even get
to the first round.
And really, I'd like
to echo Bill's comment.
It's really taking part can
generate so much enthusiasm
for doing something more.
And it's not just
winning, but taking part.
But let's get to
the exciting part.
It says here co
grand prize winner,
and the team is Direct Hit.
[APPLAUSE]
GARY CULLISS: This is
absolutely amazing.
I just want to say how
incredible this competition is
it.
We are here because
of the competition.
We would have never
met each other.
I am just-- I want to introduce
Steven Yang, one of the team
members that you've heard a
little bit about already, David
[? Doe, ?] also another
very valuable team member.
And I just want to
thank everybody,
all the lead organizers.
This is incredible.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
MIKE CASSIDY: Wow.
And I have one more small
surprise announcement, too.
We have been
extremely fortunate.
And between the time
we turned in our plan
until tonight, we
actually had been
approached by venture capitalist
and have achieved funding.
Because that puts us
in a slight imposition,
we have decided to give the
$30,000 to the other finalists.
We'll split it up among
the other finalists.
So thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
SCOTT BLANKSTEEN:
This was certainly
an unpredictable evening.
I don't think there was anyone
in the room who knew everything
that was going to happen
at the end of this,
including the judges.
So here we are.
First of all, let's, again,
just give our congratulations
to everybody who
took part this year.
[APPLAUSE]
And to reward you for your
patience and your interest,
we have some food afterwards,
some light refreshments,
and a little time to mingle
and network a little more.
Before we go, don't forget to
sign up for our mailing list,
to keep in touch with
all the great stuff
we'll be doing next year
on our 10th anniversary.
And the final thought, maybe--
goodnight.
[APPLAUSE]